hello we are the cast of sex education
and we're here with glamour uk and we're
going to play
guess the sex education
[Music]
okay so what do you call it when you
have like an infatuation for someone you
fancy obsessed not as strong as that you
weren't in there really straight i'm
talking you know you've got you kind of
tried you found i know um fantasizing
it's kind of a young thing yes you have
a crush on them i have a crush on you
what is gene milburn uh mother what else
is she milf yes a therapist physical
therapist
where does maeve live house caravan
caravan have you watched it
what's the name of our show
specification what
not not boxing but another kind of
fighting
um
it's kind of people performing they
don't really oh wrestling yes wrestling
uh what what school do we go to dale
high school
well done babies
we're out of it
ready
to
cross start like lovers
uh beautiful people they're in a trio in
our school the untouchables yep
um so if you are on a vehicle it's kind
of similar
right you're what are you doing when
you're doing that cycling but what are
you doing you're creating
we work in sometimes uh it's not film
it's tv it's not film it's movies it's
not that it's hollywood it's not that
it's no
no you did a play
theater yep so when we were on the bus
at the back of the bus what did we all
have female solidarity yes
um okay you can trap someone um on a
planet
trap planet
and
trap a planet you can trap someone in a
planet think of a planet that begins
with v
venus
okay so what are we practicing right now
um by being mate and hanging out and
social love it's like we are friendships
it's like okay say i like you are uh
he's a he's a tough lad pass
yes
i'm a woman and also i could also be a
man or non-binary
i believe that women
should get paid properly and equality
feminism yes
brilliant
when i was trying to describe something
earlier i basically used them all what
is it cringe no swear words no no no no
we're talking about gender
gender pronouns perfect oh
the first time i ever experienced this
was in a bus stop in colchester the
train station what is it
yes
um and right you just like tell the time
watch watch yeah clock the clock
technique
what what's the clock difficult
works but it doesn't work
[Music]
oh my god
thank you so much
i'm really happy you're brilliant
well done